.
>> I'M GREG GUTFELD, ALONG WITH
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO, JESSE
WATTERS, AND SHE ALMOST DROWNED
AT THE BEACH, BUT THE LIFEGUARD
THREW HER A CHEERIO, DANA
PERINO.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS, THERE'S NO
SUCH THING AS A QUICK ONE.
I'M OUT OF HERE.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
>> INSPIRATIONAL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN CUTTING HIS
LOSSES AFTER A DUMPSTER FIRE
PRESS CONFERENCE WHERE HE TRIED
TO CONVINCE THE WORLD EVERYTHING
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP IS JUST
DANDY.
HE'S PUT AT 38% APPROVAL, THE
LOWEST OF HIS PRESIDENCY SO FAR.
BIDEN GETTING ASKED WHY SO MANY
AMERICANS THINK THE COUNTRY IS
ON THE WRONG TRACK, BUT ALL HE
COULD MUSTER UP WAS HIS USUAL
NONSENSE ON RUSSIA AND BOGUS
CLAIMS ABOUT INFLATION.
>> I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE OF INFLATION, BUT
INFLATION IS HIGHER IN ALMOST
EVERY OTHER COUNTRY.
PRICES AT THE PUMP ARE HIGHER IN
ALMOST EVERY OTHER COUNTRY.
WE'RE BETTER POSITIONED TO DEAL
WITH THIS, BUT WE HAVE A WAY TO
GO.
ULTIMATELY THE REASON GAS PRICES
ARE UP IS BECAUSE OF RUSSIA.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
>> HOW LONG IS IT FAIR TO EXPECT
AMERICAN DRIVERS AND DRIVERS
AROUND THE WORLD TO PAY THAT
PREMIUM FOR THIS WAR?
>> AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
RUSSIA CANNOT IN FACT DEFEAT
UKRAINE AND MOVE BEYOND UKRAINE.
>> JEEZ LOUISE.
AND THE GUY WHO HELPED OBAMA GET
ELECTED THINK JOE ISN'T CUT OUT
FOR THIS LINE OF WORK.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT GOT INTO
THOSE QUESTIONS, GAS PRICES AND
INFLATION AND ABORTION RIGHTS,
THERE WAS A LOT LESS OF THAT
CERTAINTY, A LOT LESS OF THAT
EMPHATIC NATURE OF HIS INITIAL
PRESENTATION ON NATO, BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T HAVE GREAT ANSWERS.
>> AS THINGS GO SOUTH, BIDEN IS
BEING FORCED TO APPLY FOR THE
JOB HE ALREADY HAS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TRYING TO
CONVINCE DEMOCRATS AT
FUNDRAISERS HE'S READY FOR 2024,
ARGUING THAT HE'S THE ONLY ONE
WHO CAN BEAT TRUMP.
APPARENTLY JESSICA, HE'S HOPING
THAT TRUMP RUNS.
YOU KNOW, DO YOU BELIEVE HE'S
RUNNING IN 2024?
BE HONEST.
LET'S PRETEND WE'RE NOT ON TV
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE JUST AT A BAR HAVING A
DRINK.
>> THIS WOULD NOT BE WHAT I
WOULD TALK ABOUT IF WE WERE AT A
BAR HAVING A DRINK.
I ACTUALLY DO THINK THAT HE'S
PLANNING ON RUNNING IN 2024.
HE'S IN 20 HEALTH.
I THINK HE DOES HAVE A STRONG
CASE BASED ON 2020 THAT HE'S THE
ONLY ONE THAT COULD BEAT TRUMP.
>> WHAT'S YOUR DEFINITION OF
HEALTH?
>> HE COULD RUN LONGER THAN I
COULD.
>> SO CAN A CLOCK, BUT YOU NEED
SOMETHING WITH A BRAIN.
>> I'M SORRY.
I'M GOING TO SHIFT A LITTLE BIT
HERE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING, WHEN YOU SEE
DAVID ALLE ROD, YOU SEE THE REAL
FISSURES BETWEEN OBAMA WORLD AND
BIDEN WORLD.
THEY'RE GETTING A LITTLE BIT OF
THOSE JABS.
THERE'S STILL RESENTMENT
OBVIOUSLY ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
2016, HILLARY NOT WINNING,
CARRYING ON OBAMA'S LEGACY, AND
GENUINE CONCERN THAT IN 2024, IF
IT IS IN MY OPINION BUT TRUMP, I
THINK TRUMP IS THE EASIEST
CANDIDATE FOR DEMOCRATS TO BEAT
IN 2024 THAT WE WILL END UP
LOSING.
HE'S CORRECT ABOUT THESE BAD
ANSWERS.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHY BIDEN
CAN'T SAY IT'S A TOUGH TIME, AND
IT'S A TOUGH TIME IN A LOT OF
COUNTRIES, AND WE DON'T HAVE TO
COMPARE THEM.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO YOU'RE DOING
BETTER THAN THESE PLACES.
YOU'RE OVER THERE PRESENTING AS
A UNIT, RIGHT, WITH YOUR NATO
ALLIES.
JUST TALK ABOUT THAT, AND JUST
SAY EVERYONE IS SUFFERING, THIS
CAN'T BE ALL RUSSIA'S FAULT.
WE DO KNOW ABOUT GAS PRODUCTION
ACTUALLY INCREASING IN THE
UNITED STATES, BUT JUST OWN IT A
LITTLE BIT.
AMERICANS WILL SMILE FONDLY UPON
THAT.
THE THEY'RE COOL WITH THE HONEST
TRUTH ABOUT IT.
DOESN'T MEAN NECESSARILY YOU'LL
WIN THE ELECTION, BUT YOU WON'T
HAVE THESE NEWS CYCLES ABOUT
BEING DETACHED FROM REALITY.
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY NOT HELPFUL TO
THE PRESIDENCY.
>> HE CAN'T HELP HIM, THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
YOU'RE ASKING HIM TO CHANGE HIS
STRIPES, AND HE CAN BARELY HIS
CHANTS.
JESSE, WE HAVE HYPERINFLATION, A
CRIME WAVE, GENERAL MALAISE.
HE BASICALLY SAID, YEAH, WE'RE
IN IT, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY FOR A NEVERENDING WAR, YOU
HAVE TO SUCK IT UP.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> THAT'S HIS POLICY.
HIS POLICY IS TO BOG RUSSIA DOWN
IN UKRAINE AND BLEED THEM DRY,
AND IT COULD TAKE YEARS.
>> THE RUBLE IS DOING FINE.
>> TO THE AMERICAN DRIVER THAT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A PLAN TO
REDUCE GAS PRICES.
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE A PLAN
AT ALL.
HIS POLICY IS BASICALLY THINGS
ARE BAD, NOT AS BAD AS MEXICO,
AND NONE OF IT IS MY FAULT, AND
I HAVE NO PLANS TO FIX IT.
YOU CAN'T TELL THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT.
YOU CAN'T TELL AMERICAN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INFLATION IS BAD
BUT IT'S WORSE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE DON'T LIVE SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WE LIVE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT CRIME, YOU SHOULD SEE
BRAZIL.
WE DON'T LIVE IN BRAZIL.
WE LIVE HERE.
AND THEN HE KEEPS ON SAYING, OH,
WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S RUSSIA'S
FAULT WITH THE GAS AND
INFLATION.
THE FED CHAIR LAST WEEK CAME OUT
AND SAID IT'S NOT.
HE'S WALKING THROUGH A BLOWNUP
TALKING POINT, GETTING SHRAPNEL
ALL IN HIS CALVES, AND HE
DOESN'T EVEN FEEL IT.
HE'S OBLIVIOUS TO THE FACT THAT
HE'S MAKING NO SENSE AT ALL.
HE'S BEEN TO EUROPE AT LEAST
TWICE.
HAS HE EVER BEEN TO AN OIL RIG?
HAS HE EVER BEEN TO THE BORDER?
HAS HE EVER BEEN TO A BABY
FORMULA FACTORY?
HAS HE BEEN ANYWHERE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE SAY, YEAH,
THAT'S WHERE YOU SHOULD BE.
NO.
HE LOVES FLYING ACROSS THE
ATLANTIC AND TALKING ABOUT NATO.
>> YEAH.
HE KNOWS THE UKRAINIAN BORDER
QUITE WELL, JUDGE.
IT LOOKS LIKE TO ME WE'LL BE
PAYING FOR A FOREIGN WAR FOR A
LONG TIME WHILE WE SUFFER.
GAS PRICES AREN'T GOING AWAY.
THEY'RE GOING UP.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THE AMAZING
PART OF IT IS, YOU REMEMBER WHEN
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE THE ADULT IN THE
ROOM?
HE USES EVERY EXCUSE LIKE A
CHILD'S EXCUSE.
YOU HEARD HIM SAY WHEN HE WAS
ASKED A QUESTION AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, "I'M OUTTA HERE,"
LIKE A KID PICKING UP HIS BALL
AND BAT AND SAYING "I'M OUTHERE,
I'M NOT PLAYING WITH YOU
ANYMORE."
I DIDN'T DO IT.
IT'S HIS FAULT.
HE FORGOT THAT HE LET RUSSIA GET
OIL AND START THE WAR.
HE DOESN'T ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THAT.
HE DOESN'T TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE FACT THAT
HE'S LYING, HE'S OPENLY LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
EVERYONE'S INFLATION IS WORSE
THAN OURS.
THAT IS A FACT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
STATISTICALLY PROVEN.
YOU KNOW, HE JUST SAYS IT AND HE
GETS AWAY WITH IT.
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
AREN'T OUT THERE SAYING, JOE, GO
GET 'EM, YOU'RE THE BEST.
YOU'VE GOT A DEPRESSED COUNTRY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
YOU'VE GOT A FEARFUL COUNTRY.
FAMILIES ARE WORRIED ABOUT DRUGS
COMING THROUGH THE BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T EVEN GIVE US
GOOD NEWS.
HOW LONG ARE WE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY THESE PRICES?
OH, I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE WAR.
IT'S RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
THAT DIDN'T WORK FOR THE FIRST
FOUR YEARS OF TRUMP'S TURN.
SO THEY'LL TRY IT AGAIN.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> IN HIS DEFENSE, WE SUPPORTED
THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
HE'S GIVING US WHAT WE WANT.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR FROM
HILLARY?
>> SURE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
HILLARY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> AND IF HE DECIDES TO RUN,
HE'S A SITTING PRESIDENT.
>> DO YOU ENDORSE HIM?
>> LOOK, I WOULD ENDORSE OUR
SITTING PRESIDENT.
YES, OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS A SILLY
QUESTION.
LET'S GO TO THE PERSON MOST
LIKELY TO WIN.
JOE BIDEN BEAT IN A HUGE
LANDSLIDE VICTORY IN THE POPULAR
VOTE DONALD TRUMP.
THAT SAYS A LOT.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SHE'S OUT THERE, BUT ALSO
GOVERNOR PRITZKER OF ILLINOIS
SAID TODAY, HE BASICALLY PUT IT
ON THE TABLE, THAT HE WANTS TO
PRIMARY HIM, THAT HE WANTS TO
RUN.
THE PRESIDENT IS COMING BACK TO
THE UNITED STATES WITH NO GOOD
ANSWERS.
THERE ARE WAYS TO BRING DOWN GAS
PRICES WHILE YOU ALSO SUPPORT
THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
YOU COULD DRILL FOR MORE HERE.
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO BE AN
ANSWER THAT HE PROVIDES.
YOU CAN DO THAT.
HE JUST WON'T DO THAT.
INSTEAD WHAT'S THE NEXT TRIP
HE'S TAKING?
IT'S NOT TO THE BORDER.
IT'S TO SAUDI ARABIA.
PEOPLE IN HIS ADMINISTRATION
MAKING A TRIP DOWN TO VENEZUELA
SUPPOSEDLY TO TALK TO ONE OF THE
AMERICANS BEING HELD THERE.
WE ALSO KNOW THEY WERE GOING TO
SEE IF VENEZUELA COULD START
PUMPING MORE OIL.
THE PIECE CALLED "THE ELEPHANT
IN THE ZOOM" ABOUT THE
INFIGHTING AMONG THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHERE THE POLITICAL
FIGHTING IS.
THEY LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS, BUT THIS IS A
FRACTURED PARTY